Cyndi's with us in Houston Texas hi
Cindy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave
nice to speak to you I have a question
my 82 year old saw their mom recently
moved in with us and me and my husband
are not in agreement I felt like he
should be contributing to the household
expenses my husband doesn't think he
should so how did he move in without you
two being an agreement first
exactly it kind of was thrown on as he
was either gonna come here or he was
going to be in the nursing home so it
was like we had 24 hours to make a
decision and not typically nursing home
we brought them home so you guys did not
have a unity prior to making a decision
this large what was our marital mistake
on your else part so now you've got
marital discord and an 88 year old man
in the crossfire we sure didn't know yes
so if he who was going to pay for the
nursing home if he went it was going to
come out of his retirement and there's
any bet he had so he should contribute
out of his retirement and the money that
he has to your household income I agree
what is your household income today it
is ninety four thousand yeah what's your
net worth you're you and your husband
well we're not something there is
another word and ninety five thousand
dollars in death so oh my god you're
$95,000 in death
what's your income yes we're not the
important our income nearly is a 94 tell
your 94 in debt and you have a 94 income
yes enough okay mm-hmm that's confusing
as crud how old are you - I am 50 and my
husband 49 and he has an 88 year old
father okay so he's 40 when he had him
okay yes okay
does he have siblings your husband he
does but unfortunately my husband is so
care for her not money and I think it's
wonderful that
taking care of his down I think that's
all fine the thing is that you're his
brothers and sisters are profiting off
of you while you're broke because you're
supporting the care of this gentleman
living with you and he should pay you
what he pays some portion of what he
would have paid the nursing home that's
fair that reduces his estate and thereby
what brothers and sisters will get upon
his passing but that is what would
happen had he been in a nursing home a
matter of fact it would have been
reduced even more and he would have had
a different quality of life he gets the
wonderful thing of living with you guys
yeah yeah so I think it is fair for him
to contribute something maybe not
completely equal to what the nursing
home would have cost but free is not
fair it's not right it's not right
because when your father-in-law dies
your brother your brothers and
sisters-in-law are gonna get more money
that would have been in your pocket and
your ninety four thousand dollars in
debt and that's not right because
they're contributing nothing to his care
zero Zippo mmm-hmm
and so my brother and sister-in-law
lived next door to my father-in-law and
do a wonderful job looking over him and
I would do anything for them because
they have all of that on them and I'm in
the other end of the state Sharon and I
think they're amazing and they will
never bear any cost it's in excess of
what the rest of us chip in because we
are thankful they're there to take care
of em and that's ought to be the
position of this family